اكد مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني غير متورطه
على الاطلاق في هجمات العام الماضي التي
استهدفت خط انابيب الغاز نور ستريم ولا
معلومات لديها عما حدث وقتها تصريح حاجه
ردا على معلومات نشراتها صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز نقلا عن مسؤولين امريكيين تفيد
بتورط جماعه مناصره لاوكرانيا في هذا
الهجوم الذي وجه وقتها الغرب اصابع
الاتهام لروسيا بالوقوف وراءه
المعلومات التي نشرتها ايضا حول تورط مع
الناصره لاوكرانيا في هجوم نورس مع الحدث
مع خالد الغرابلي خالد اهلا بك اولا ما
الذي جاء في هذه المعلومات التي نشرتها ما
التفاصيل التي اوردتها نقلا دائما عن
مسؤولين امريكيين على ما قاموا بالعمليه
هي مجموعه مناصره لاوكرانيا هل يعني ذلك
انهم عناصر من الجيش الاوكراني لا لا حديث
عن انهم عناصر من الجيش الاوكراني لا حديث
عن وجود دليل
انسكي متورط او امر بمثل هذا الهجوم اذا
من هم هم جماعه بحسب هذه المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه التي كشف عنها مسؤولون
امريكيون
هم جماعه قد يكونون من المواطنين
الاوكرانيين او الروس او مزيج من الاثنين
لكن وهذه معلومه في غايه الاهميه الروس
ليسوا متورطين في هذا الهجوم هذه معلومات
الامريكيون هم الذين يكشفون عنها لم يقم
بها لا امريكي ولا بريطاني لان روسيا
كانوا يشكون في الامريكيين والبريطانيين
طيب ماذا نعرف ايضا عن هؤلاء هم من
الغواصين المهره يتمتعون بكفاءه عاليه جدا
لكن لا يبدو بحسب هذه المعلومات لا يبدو
انهم يعملون لحساب جيش او جهاز استخبارات
لكن حصلوا على خبرات عسكريه سابقه
كيف حصلوا على استخبارات عسكريه سابقه وهم
لا يعملون الان لحساب جيش هذه هذا التناقض
الظاهري لا يوجد تفسير اليه فيما نقلته عن
المسؤولين الامريكيين لكن في النهايه
التقرير نيور تايمز يشير الى معلومه كان
مصدرها اوروبا ان المعدات المتفجرات
المستخدمه ذات جوده عسكريه اي انها ليس
لاي شخص ان يستطيع ان يصل اليها بسهوله
يعني ومن الاسئله التي تطرح طبعا خالد هل
من الممكن ان تكون جماعه اوكرانيه او
مناصره لاوكرانيا قد قامت بكل هذا الهجوم
الذي يحتاج لامكانيات عاليه دون علم كيف
او سلطات هناك هجوم يحتاج الى امكانيات
عاليه جدا وله تداعيات اقتصاديه وعسكريه
وسياسيه في غايه الخطوره قد لا يهم اي
جماعه عاديه ان تقوم به الا اذا كانت
وراءها دوله وهنا يصعد تخيل حقيقه ان تقوم
جماعه مواليه لاوكرانيا بفعل هذا بدون ان
يكون هناك ضوء اخضر من الاوكرانيين وهذا
يفتح الباب على سؤال اخر وهو لا يقل اهميه
على الاطلاق رجاء السؤال هو لماذا لماذا
يكشف مسؤولون امريكيون عن شكوك قد تصيب
اسهمها الحكومه الاوكرانيه لانه حتى وان
قلنا انه لا يوجد دليل على ان الحكومه
الاوكرانيه مطارطه في هذا الموضوع مجرد ان
يذكر الموضوع انها جماعه مناصره لاوكرانيا
في النهايه الشبهه ستكون قويه على الحكومه
الاوكرانيه طيب اذا لماذا يحاول يكشف
الامريكيون عن معلومات قد تسيء لحليف
اساسي لهم في هذه الحرب خاصه ان بحسب هذه
المعلومات استخباراتيه لكن لم نعلم من اي
استخبارات اجت هي استخبارات اوروبيه
وامريكيه لا نعرف بدقه
ما هي تفاصيل هذه المعلومات لا تعرف كل
التفاصيل انما مجرد تسريبات كشافها بعض
المسؤولين لم نعرف من هم اساسا لكن نعرف
انهم مسؤولون امريكيون طيب هل هناك ادله
قويه على ما جاء في هذه الاتهامات ايضا لا
اشاره على نوعيه الادله اذا كانت هناك
ادله بل حتى ان نيويورك تايم تقول ان
المسؤولين الامريكيين منقسمون حول اهميه
هذه المعلومات ولهذا نعود مره اخرى سؤال
ان كانت هناك شكوك ربما حول اهميه هذه
المعلومات لماذا ينشر المسؤولين امريكيون
هذه المعلومات التي ستصيب الحكومه
الاوكرانيه بشكل او باخر ربما تكون لهم
مصلحه في الضغط على الحكومه الاوكرانيه
لاتخاذ موقف سياسي معين تفاوض او اتخاذ
موقف عسكري معين الانسحاب من بخمت على
السيد المثال ان يكون هؤلاء الذين سربوا
في المعلومات يحاولون ابعاد الشبهات عن
واشنطن بعد طبعا حديث بان بالفعل واشنطن
هي من يقف وراء التفجير مكانه
طبعا هو كاتب امريكي معروف له تاريخ طويل
لكن في النهايه هو ما تحدث عنه اتهامات
شفهيه لم يقدم اي دليل ولو كان هناك دليل
على ان الامريكيين وراء مثل هذا الهجوم
كان روسي استخدموه منذ زمن طويل حتى في
المحاكم الدوليه ضد الولايات المتحده لكن
لا يوجد دليل يثبت تورط الجانب الامريكي
في مثل هذه العمليات وبالتالي ما وجه من
اتهام هو اتهام شفهي قامت الاقامه السلطات
الامريكيه ردت عليه بطريقه شفهيه ويكاد
يكون الموضوع نسي تقريبا الموضوع وبالتالي
الامريكان ليسوا في حاجه على الدفاع
انفسهم في هذا الموضوع
خاصه انا ليس لهم مصلحه كبيره ربما في
استهداف السيد الشمالي واحد واثنان سيل
الشمالي اثنان لم يكن يعمل بالاساس في تلك
الفتره الامريكيون ضغطوا قبلها بشهور على
الالمان واوقفوا العمل بهذا الشمالي اثنين
سالي الشمالي واحد كان الروس اوقفوه جزئيا
عن العمل بحجه اصلاحات وفي النهايه
الاوروبيون كانوا وضعوا خطه للتخلص من
الغاز الروسي يعني كان مصلحه الامريكيين
هي دفع الاوروبيين للتخلص من الغاز الروسي
في ذلك الوقت كانت خطه وضعت بالفعل وكان
الاوروبيون في طريقهم الى التنفيذ اذا كان
الهدف هو زياده الاسعار لكي يتمكن
الامريكيون من بيع غازهم الاسعار كانت
مرتفعه والامريكان كان يبعون هذا وليسوا
في حاجه للقيام بمثل هذه العمليه لمصلحه
اقتصاديه معينه لك خالد الغراب على وقفه
مع الحدث